joining me now is texas congressman troy
nails and florida congressman byron
donalds both were sworn into office just
days before january 6.
congressman nails you were famously
photographed
talking down a rioter at the window of
the house chamber
there you are in blue
you were face to face with them and you
were originally appointed to the january
6 committee so you watched tonight
what are your thoughts
well liz almost put me to sleep
and and but we knew this was going to
take place
uh i watched the first 30 40 minutes and
i can't tell you how many times she used
trump's name
she's not talking and this committee has
no intent to talk about why the capitol
police were so ill prepared to deal with
that day and they were and the sad part
about it is the intelligence was there
and i've been saying for the past 17 18
months when you look at the leadership
team of the capitol police and the
intelligence it was glaring them in the
face
we all knew that they were gonna that
the capital was the target we all knew
that there were white supremacist
malicious extremist groups going to be
there we knew that there was a
propensity for violence we knew they
were going to be armed
all the information was there in these
intelligence assessments
and the leadership of the capitol police
did nothing with it
but you have to know that the leadership
of the capitol police answers to nancy
pelosi speaker pelosi she runs the
security apparatus around our nation's
capital they had all the intelligence
they didn't act upon it because in my
humble opinion through my research
they wanted it to happen they didn't
care if this happened you saw some of
the video of the oath keepers and the
proud boys the capitol police knew weeks
in advance that they were going to be
there so what what okay we get it the
national guard should have been there is
my point so so there was there was a lot
of conversations out there some of them
were you know dismissed by the left that
the administration had offered the
national guard
to actually you know deploy before
january 6 to protect
their capital and that was declined is
that true or false according to what you
know
there's a lot of finger pointing
with the capitol police board which is
the architect of the capitol the house
sergeant at arms and the senate
sergeant-at-arms and they are the ones
that would have to declare the emergency
to get the national guard there and what
i know is through my research is is the
house sergeant-at-arms uh irving who's
no longer there he was waiting to get
approval from leadership the approval
from leadership is nancy pelosi all
right congressman donald's you know they
they aren't really just content to
punish
uh people who broke the law or political
opponents even for that matter uh for
what they perceive to be sins of the
past but ones they assure us are going
to happen going forward watch
our work
must do much more than just look
backwards
because of our democracy remains in
danger
the conspiracy to thought the will of
the people is not over
what does that mean congressman so if
they lose in the midterms is that part
of their erosion of democracy that
they're worried about
i believe so listen i watched the entire
two hours of this mess and the reality
is is that all they're doing is trying
to paint a new political narrative that
voters need to think about in november
because the democrat agenda has failed
we all know the reasons why no need to
recap
but to throw this out there that there's
somehow this danger to democracy that
exists is ludicrous people are voting
right now all across the country there
are no issues americans are letting
their voices being heard at the ballot
box in many cities and states across the
country there are no issues i don't know
what they're talking about except to
cover up for their disastrous agenda
that has hurt every aspect of american
life well and congressman nails
we kept hearing early on that a lot of
these people who were arrested you know
were being kept in solitary confinement
um under pretty you know terrible
conditions
uh in many cases
not able to talk to their family members
kept for months and months and months
pending i guess
trial
what do we know of that tonight
and and i was told that these
individuals here in the in the
washington dc gulag would rather be
transferred to quan domino bay because
they treat the terrorists better
that's what we do know and it's
interesting i had a family from my
district call me and said there that her
husband was arrested on tuesday the fbi
barricaded the entire sweet street there
were fbi agents in the backyard had a
one-year-old and a three-year-old at
home and here the fbi is coming in with
their guns blazing the fbi needs to tone
it down a little bit this is getting
ridiculous what we're seeing and now
this individual is being charged and
he's being held he's going to be now
taken away from his family he's been
home for 18 months 17 months and now
they're arresting him and keeping him
away from his family we're going to do
everything we can to try to help this
family all right congressman donalds i
want to play another moment from the
chairman benny thompson
i'm from a part of the country where
people justify the actions of slavery
the ku klux klan and lynching
i'm reminded of that dark history as i
hear voices today
try and justify the actions of the
insurrectionists on january 6 20 21
is equating january 6 and slavery the
kkk
even though some of these proud boys i
believe were minorities themselves right
including the leadership is this
effective i mean i don't know where he
was going with that
it's just more gaslighting from benny
thompson thompson in from the left
listen everybody knows slavery was
disastrous for the united states but
nobody's trying to equate that to
january 6 number one and number two
every republican who was in the capitol
building we all did not agree with what
happened on january 6 we've all
denounced the violence of january 6. it
is purely unacceptable but the
gaslighting from the democrats remain
when they try to find some way to
salvage the fact that they don't know
actually how to run a country like the
united states of america because their
agenda is flawed it's terrible it
doesn't help americans try to actually
live their lives today and going forward
now congressman nails before we go i
want to remind everyone of the carnage
that was unleashed the chaos
that was unleashed by the left often to
you know no comment by democrats on
capitol hill back in 2020 more than 2
000 law enforcement officers were
injured during the blm riots causing a
record-setting 2 billion dollars in
damages nationwide
congressman did we ever
have democrat-led hearings on any of
this
absolutely not and why because it was
antifa and blm they're the ones that
committed all these rights in the summer
2020 destroying our buildings killing
people killing lots of people police
officers injuring just causing chaos
around our entire country but there was
blm and it was antifa so now they're
going after some of these individual
these groups that came up to washington
dc that felt an election was stolen and
they voiced their concerns and their
opinions yes those that went into that
capital and assaulted law enforcement
should go to jail i'm a law man you
should go to jail because you shouldn't
put your hands on any law enforcement
but you're not going to see the
thousands of people that were up there
and hundreds that were inside that
building that were walking around doing
absolutely nothing and these individuals
their lives are being ruined by uh by an
fbi that is just doing horrible things
to these people by a doj a corrupt fbi
enough is enough thank you congressman
both of you good to see you tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else